[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: We're
now in the IoT tent.
And first, we're going to
learn all about OpenThread
from Jonathan.
JONATHAN: All right.
So OpenThread is an open-source
implementation of the Thread
networking protocol.
What it is is a low-power
mesh networking technology
that allows devices,
IoT devices,
to talk to each other over
a low-power mesh network.
So if you're building
products that
run on battery that's supposed
to last for years, not months,
Thread's a great
solution for that.
So what we've done at
Nest is taken the protocol
and made an open-source
implementation,
put it in our products, and
made it available to developers
to build into their own ones.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
JONATHAN: Yeah.
So you want me to walk
you through the demo here?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah, can
you show me what's going on?
JONATHAN: So all these
devices you see on the wall
are actually running OpenThread.
They're running our
partner hardware.
And they're connected to
a single-thread network,
one giant mesh network.
And one of the benefits of
Thread, it's actually using IP.
So just Internet Protocol.
And each device
has an IP address--
an IPv6 address, to be specific.
And that makes it really
easy for developers
to build apps because it's
just IP that they're used to.
So if you can ping a web server,
you can ping a Thread node.
So in this demo, we're actually
showing pinging a device
over the Thread network.
So as you see that light
blink, it's actually
going over Wi-Fi
from this tablet
to this Raspberry Pi, which
happens to be on Wi-Fi,
and then fanning out
to the Thread network.
And you can imagine
sensors or actuators
like door locks and windows
being replaced by an LED,
but we're just simplifying
it with this demonstration.
It's really cool.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
Thank you so much.
JONATHAN: Sure thing.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hey,
before we go, actually,
if developers want to get
started, where do they go?
JONATHAN: Sure.
It's been publicly
available for the last year.
We launched it at
Google I/O last year.
And you can go on
github.com/opent
hread/openthread.
There's codelabs available
if you're here at Google I/O,
but it's also available on the
Google Codelab website for you
to try it at home.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: I see a
golden retriever.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's
a golden retriever.
That's pretty great.
So we're in the
Android Things room.
And I'm here with
Ryan and Wayne.
Ryan, tell us about some
of the stuff that is built
on Android Things in this room.
RYAN: Cool.
Do I get to hold it?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Sure.
RYAN: All right.
So over here, we
have a simple demo
that we are using
to show how easy it
is to go from prototype to
production with Android Things.
So at the top, we have
a very simple light
that's turned on using
an Intel Edison kit.
Over here, we're
using the design,
but we used a custom PCB to
make the footprint smaller.
Therefore, you can
fit the overall thing
into a smaller form factor.
At the bottom, you
can see in the candle.
WAYNE: And actually, the really
cool part about that demo
is that any developer can make
a circuit board like that.
So in our talk
tomorrow, we're going
to show you how to actually
build that circuit board.
And you can actually
solder this up
in your own workshop or
home, so it's actually
one of the really cool
things about the [INAUDIBLE]
architecture is you can do that.
RYAN: Yep.
On the right, we have the
TensorFlow camera demo.
This is also running
on Android Things.
We have Raspberry Pi 3 camera.
And it's actually fairly
easy to build as well.
All these parts
are off the shelf.
So you'll notice that--
WAYNE: There's a
battery in it too.
RYAN: It's running on
battery, completely portable.
And the best part
is it's actually
running offline, completely
locally on the device.
So we're running the
TensorFlow model.
TensorFlow Inception
model you can get online.
And then, once we download
it, install it as an APK here,
now you don't need
online at all.
So you don't need data cost
associated with it at all.
So when I press
this button, it will
take a picture using the
camera module located here.
And then it will be
processed on the device,
and it'll say what
it thinks it is
using Android text-to-speech.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Tell me
about the M&Ms over here.
RYAN: So on this one,
this was actually
built by one of our
external developers
in our community, Lewis.
So the small candy
dispenser, it's
powered by Android Things
using Raspberry Pi 3.
And once you press
this button, the camera
will take a picture of
you, send that image
through Cloud Vision API.
And if it detects a smile,
it will give you the candy.
And we're using our relay
module, as you can see here,
connected to the
motor of the dispenser
to activate the dispensing.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
All right, y'all.
Well, I think that's
all the Android Things
that we're going to
check out in this booth.
Wayne, before we get
going, what are some things
that developers can do today
to play with Android Things?
WAYNE: The really cool thing
is all these samples here,
we've open-sourced all of them.
So the TensorFlow image
recognition, the LED candle.
We've released all the
source code on GitHub.
The schematics for
the candle are also
available as an
actual circuit design,
so you can actually
make them yourself.
So you can try all
these things out.
And then it's really
easy to get started.
You use Android Studio
to write your code.
And it's really
easy to get going.
So any Android programmer
who's written a phone app now
has the ability to
make IoT apps as well.
So that's one of the really cool
things about Android Things,
is it takes advantage of all of
your existing Android knowledge
and allows you to apply it here.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right.
We're now in the
Works With Nest room.
And I'm here with
Jesse, who's going
to tell us a little bit
about Works With Nest.
JESSE: Yeah, thanks
for stopping by.
So Works With Nest is a
developer program for Nest.
And we have a bunch
of different APIs
that let you connect
into the Nest ecosystem.
And there's a lot of ways
that you can connect.
You can connect to the
thermostat, the camera,
the smoke alarm, and then, also,
our demand-response programs
that we set up with utility
companies across the country.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
So what are some of your
favorite integrations
with the Works
With Nest program?
JESSE: So some of the
really cool ones are--
whoa-- over here.
The Aware, it's an
air quality sensor.
And it will measure the
different things in your air.
And then how it
integrates with Nest
is it connects to a
thermostat and uses the fan
to clean up the
air in your house
when it detects that
levels are high.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Oh, that's cool.
What else?
JESSE: Another one
that's really cool which
is a little different.
It's not directly
connecting with--
they're all over-- products
is the Rachio sprinkler.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
JESSE: So I have it at my house.
It manages the
water automatically,
so I don't have to worry
about it in my yard.
But with Nest, it shows
up in my home report
every month, where Nest
tells me how much energy I'm
using with my
thermostat, but then
I also have a list of
how much water I've used
and compares it to
the previous month.
Pretty cool.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Cool.
So that's some of
the stuff that's
been around for a little bit.
What's next?
What's the newest integrations?
JESSE: So some of our new
things are with the camera.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
JESSE: So the camera is now
connected to the thermostat--
or to the APIs.
And we're doing cool
new things there.
So originally, you could use
the APIs and get motion events,
and then have your products
respond to motion in the house.
But lately, we've been
developing our ImageVision.
And now we can recognize people.
So now Works With Nest products
can get these people events
and do things when they
know that there's a person.
One example is, not
necessarily with people
but cool integrations
with the camera,
is Chamberlain and garage doors.
So what they do is, when
the garage door opens,
they grab a snapshot
from the thermostat,
and they integrate, then,
their history UI in their app.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
JESSE: Totally.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK,
so one last question,
because we also
checked out OpenThread.
Is there anything in
here that's using Thread?
JESSE: Absolutely.
So super excited about Thread.
It's really like the next phase
of our development program.
The first one is giving
people an easy way
to connect to Nest products.
And then phase two,
we're going to take
some of the core
technology that we've
developed at Nest to
build our Nest products
and make it available
for developers.
So we're working with
Yale on this lock.
Yale's been making locks
for 50 years, 100 years.
And they're really good at
it, but not really a software
company.
So we've taken some
of the software
that we use on our Nest
products like Thread
and made it available to them.
And it's going to be a
really cool lock that's
integrated with the ecosystem.
And we've actually
open-sourced Thread.
And we have a booth
just a couple of booths
down where you can
see all about it
and figure out
where to get code.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Is there anything
else you'd like
to tell to all the
developers out there?
JESSE: Check out the codelabs.
We have an OpenThread codelab.
We have one with the camera
that integrates with TensorFlow.
It's fun stuff that you can
do for the next two days.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Thanks, Jesse.
JESSE: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]